uc irvine and she's going to tell us
about fresh
off the press joint work with uh duit
arunov on
um complexity of hamiltonians in the
thermodynamics limit
um thank you tahan and thank you
inviting for inviting me to speak here
today it's good to be back in berkeley
um i wanted to mention specifically that
we found out very recently
that toby cubitt and his student james
watson
have been working on very similar
results to these and we coordinated our
posting to the archive so
both papers were posted over the weekend
and will appear
sometime this evening in the u.s early
morning in
europe and israel so i encourage you to
look at both papers
um all right so this is probably
i'll start out with familiar territory
to many of you um
uh ketaya sort of kicked off the the
study of
hamiltonian complexity by introducing
the local hamiltonian problem
it's a classical problem in condensed
matter physics but also sort of a
quantum generalization of sat
you have a input hamiltonian which is a
sum of local terms
and two thresholds separated by one over
polynomial
in n the number of particles in your
system and you want to accept or reject
depending on whether the ground energy
of your hamiltonian is
below the lower threshold or larger than
the higher threshold
so uh and although it's
familiar territory i want to um review
uh the definition of qma because it's
actually
uh there are some subtleties that will
come up later in the talk
so a problem p it's a problem a promise
problem
partitions the set of inputs into three
categories
accept reject and invalid inputs so in
the case of the local hamiltonian an
invalid input would be this case where
the ground energy is between a and b or
two thresholds
so um the the problem is in qma
if there's some polynomial time quantum
verifier so that if x is in the reject
category there's a quantum witness that
causes
b to accept with high probability if x
is in the reject category then
no matter what witness you feed to be it
will reject with high probability
and the critical thing here for us is
that if x is invalid we have no promises
whatsoever
so normally when we're um proving qma
hardness results we don't worry too much
about this because we construct these
hamiltonians
um that whose ground state reflects the
answer to a computational problem
and we make sure in our construction
that the hamiltonians land on either
side
so it's if it's a rejecting uh
computational end up on the reject side
if it's
except it ends up on the xf side so we
just carefully craft our hamiltonians
so that they don't generate invalid uh
uh
instances in the case where we're
looking at
um qma is an oracle class it's a little
trickier
because we're going to be embedding some
computational process in the ground
state of a hamiltonian
but now we don't have any control over
the queries made to the oracle
so invalid queries could be made and we
have much less control over what happens
and this is sort of ultimately the
reason why our results aren't tight
and i'll discuss that at the end more um
in more detail
okay so cathy's construction was
far from what is commonly studied in
computational condensed matter physics
for several reasons first of all it's
non-translationally invariant
so every term is sort of tuned to the
particular particles that it operates on
it's not geometrically local five local
instead of two local
and so sort of this kind of kicked off a
sequence of results that brought
the class of qma complete problems
closer and closer to
the type of problems that might be
studied in many body physics
so two local qubits on a 2d grid
two local on a 1d chain and finally
translationally invariant on a line so
translationing theory means that
every term is exactly the same
now these are still finite systems so
what
these results are saying is what's the
complexity of determining
the ground energy as a function of the
system size
and that differs from what
a physicist might be interested in so
typically
physicists are looking at or interested
in what are the properties
energy correlation length of the ground
state as
n goes to infinity so they're really
mostly interested in this thermo
thermodynamic limit and you know we have
to
numerically you have to look at finite
system sizes out of necessity
but um really we're mostly interested in
sort of what happens
as n gets very large now this of course
requires some
notion of translational invariance
because if it's an infinite system you
can't specify
every single term individually um
so typically we think of each dimension
as having its own term
like in a 2d example here we have
two terms uh the vertical interaction
and the horizontal interaction but
as long as it's a constant dimensional
grid um it'll be a constant number of
terms
so this is what we're going to be
interested in now is what what happens
as n
goes to infinity um
and there's been some work but um
there's still a lot that's unknown
about the thermodynamic limit um there
was a breakthrough result by cubit perez
wolf
and later generalized to 1d systems
that says that given the hamiltonian
term h and now this is just the single
term that acts on two particles
and that's part of the input it's
undecidable to determine the spectral
gap
as h is applied in the thermodynamic
limit okay
and this is actually closely related to
sort of phase diagrams for their because
their h's were tuned by a
a waiting parameter and and further
developed um
in this later work on uncomputability of
phase diagrams
but what about energy and what about
sort of the computational complexity we
know that
um if all you want to know is your
ground energy to a certain precision
you can just look at a finite system and
determine that so
um so in terms of computing energies as
long as you're
bounding the precision in some way we
should this should be a computable
problem
so um
this was studied but in the context of
sort of uh
an input dependent hamiltonian term so
as a byproduct of our main results
um danielle gosman and i showed that
um if you have uh as an input you're
given the hamiltonian term
so the entries are integer multiples of
one over polynomial
and you're asked is your ground energy
below some threshold or above some
threshold this is q max complete
and x means that you have an exponential
time verifier and an exponential size
witness
and the x just comes from the fact that
your your input now is logarithmically
smaller than it would be in the size of
the system
now it makes sense to sort of question
here
does it really make sense to study this
ground energy density
in the thermodynamic limit as a function
of the hamiltonian term
because usually you think of you know
studying the hubbard problem as a
completely different problem as studying
say the icing model
so it's the h isn't so much
a function of the input h is really more
of a parameter of the problem so
for different h's i have a completely
different problem and really what you're
interested in
is given a fixed hamiltonian term what's
the complexity
of computing the energy to a certain
level of
so it's worth pointing out here that
different variations of translational
invariants have been studied
um i'm going to illustrate this first
for finite systems and then talk about
infinite systems so
in the most uh general variety you're
given as input your size of your system
the particle dimension and the
hamiltonian term itself so you're just
specified in some number of bits the
entries are given to you
in the more stricter version of
translation and variance
the hamiltonian term is a fixed
parameter of the problem and doesn't
change
so the only input to the problem in this
case
is the size of your system okay
and um this is the version that
daniel and i studied um
and wait
there we go and you can imagine an
intermediate
version of this where you have
a handful a small constant number i put
here to
fixed hamiltonian terms and those are
fixed parameters of the problem
and then you're given some input n which
is the size of your system
and the hamiltonian term that you're
applying to every pair of particles
is a weighted average and the weights
depend on the input
this is actually the most commonly
studied variety
in the in the literature is where you
still have some
input dependent aspect of your
hamiltonian term
um both are natural problems um
so this is certainly a stronger version
but you can imagine a version of
say you know fermi hubbard where you
have some weighting factor and that
weighting factor is your parameter
that's waiting two different terms
now what does this mean when we go to
infinite systems
now the n goes away because we don't
have a system size anymore
and the first two varieties of
translation invariants where there's
some input dependence
still have an infinite family of
hamiltonians to study
so if i'm interested in doing a
reduction from an infinite language
i still have an infinite family of
hamiltonians to reduce to
in this last version if i'm fixing the
hamiltonian term
as part of the problem and
now i'm studying this
this um system in the thermo
thermodynamic limit
there's really just one number it's the
it's the ground energy density
so you could ask why is it hard just to
compute a single number
um and why should this problem be hard
so let me it seems like an appropriate
time to give you that actually the
formal definition of the problem
so i'm gonna
uh express it in 2d because that's what
we uh
study in this paper um so there are two
hamiltonian terms
and i can define the n by n grid
and apply the h row in the horizontal
direction to every pair of
neighboring particles and h column in
the vertical direction
and look at the energy density so this
is the
ground energy divided by the number of
particles and let n go to infinity
so this is the this is what we're
talking about in terms of
understanding in the thermodynamic limit
and what
we capture here is the complexity of
computing this
number to a given level of precision
so here the only input to the problem
is n which tells you the desired
precision of your results
so the output we're looking at a
function problem here
the output is some number alpha and what
we require is that alpha
is within 1 over 2 to the n of the true
number that we're trying to understand
so fixed problem fixed hamiltonian
and what we're capturing here is the
complexity of
each additional bit of precision in the
output
how how complex is that to do um
you can imagine a decision version of
this problem in which we're asking for
just the nth bit
um it seemed a little artificial and as
it turns out in order to
calculate the nth point you actually
have to calculate bits 1 through n
minus 1 as well because you could
certainly verify
that the nth bit of a state of
has energy is zero or one but you have
to verify that the state that you're
measuring is the true ground state so um
ultimately
um they are roughly the same
uh complexity and this problem was
proposed by
ignacio at a simon's workshop a few
years ago so that's where we got the
idea
to work on this okay so our
proof our results are that
this problem is contained in function
exponential time to the q max and hard
for function exponential time to the
next
so there's a there's a gap here of
classical versus quantum and i will
speak to that at the end
many aspects of our construction can be
made quantum
um but there's there's a there's a
sort of an obstacle in terms of the
invalid queries that i'll discuss
at the end we still need a quantum
construction because we're still
using the you know circuit to
hamiltonian construction of catio that
represents a ground energy
so um so we
we have we start with some generic
function that's sitting inside
fx to the next um
and so we have to encode this entire
function which is an
infinite uh object on an infinite number
of inputs
into a single number but the number
itself is infinite precision
so what we do is we encode
the value of the function f on different
inputs
in different parts of the binary
representation of this alpha naught
so each additional bit gives you
information
about a new new input to the function f
okay and we use uh to start we use a
a construction that was uh initially
used by cubit garcia perez and wolf
and um of robinson tiling
and this is a fixed set of tiling rules
that in its ground state
um produces an aperiodic
structure of of um
squares of increasing size of
exponentially increasing size
so for every k there are squares of size
4 to the k and the density of those
squares
in the infinite plane is 1 over 4 to the
k squared roughly
and so this serves as a layer
of the the hamiltonian and sort of
breaks the symmetry of the infinite
plane and
um we can
and what we do is then on the second
layer we embed
a construction of a 1d translationally
invariant hamiltonian for finite chains
so um in sort of the the tiling rules
and force that on this top
row of these squares what's happening on
the layer two
is some finite construction some other
hamiltonian term that we're applying
the net result of this con this
construction is that ground energy
density in the thermodynamic limit is
this infinite sum
it's the ground energy for 1d
chain of length 4 to the k divided by
the energy density of the squares so
we're layering on top of construction
for a finite system
okay so basically what we've done now is
reduce sort of the infinite problem to
the finite problem
and so the the goal here is now to
come up with a construction for finite
chains
that answers a computational problem
um and so let's just take a closer look
at this infinite sum so if i were to
represent this sort of
graphically this is what the ground
energy looks like the red is all zeros
and that's sort of the the the right
shift
that's achieved by this um
2 to the 4k so each of these terms is
sort of staggered
and then what we're summing up
is the ground energy for a 1d chain
of a particular length 4 4 squared 4
cubed etc
now notice as we have it here these
terms are scattered
uh um staggered by only four bits which
doesn't give us quite enough room to
express a function
so the first step is um we only use
squares of a certain size we only use
squares where the exponent
is a perfect square so 4 to the x
squared
for the x plus 1 squared etc and so what
this
allows us now is it gives us a little
bit more real estate in this binary
representation of alpha naught
to express the value of the function
so um a couple things here
uh so it's these bits here in
highlighted in yellow
that's going to give us the answer to
sort of
the function that we're encoding in this
ground energy
now one thing to notice is that in order
to uncover these bits
i have to be able to subtract off all of
the previous terms
so these alpha knots in general are
going to be
the lowest eigenvalue of a finite matrix
um typically it's going to be the
laplacian of a path graph
or a psychograph plus some constant okay
so they're not going to be nice clean
rational numbers that will fit neatly
into a finite space of the binary
representation
they're going to be infinite quantities
moreover
we have to be able to subtract off all
of the preceding terms in evil
in order to uncover the bits that give
us the value of f for a particular x
so that means we have to have very
precise bounds
on these lowest eigenvalues
typical typical results on hamiltonian
complexity really only have to be
bound lower bound or upper bound these
values
so you have to show that the the ground
energy for accepting computations is
lower than some value
the ground energy for rejecting is
higher than some value it doesn't have
to be too exact
in this case we require very precise
analytical bounds for the ground
energies in order to be able to
calculate these numbers and uncover the
bits that we need
and in this case um the
um the expression that we get
is we come up with a construction where
the
we can get exact bounds analytical
bounds and the lowest
eigenvalue is of the form one minus
cosine pi over l
so an l is some integer it's bounded by
a polynomial in the system size
so if i can estimate this value
to within a given position i can uncover
the
integer l and then i can express this
value to arbitrary position using sort
of a taylor expansion
so um so one of the things one of the
techniques that we had to develop were
exact balance
constructions with where we could get
precise exact bounds on the lowest
eigenvalue
okay so as i mentioned so we've reduced
our infinite problem to a finite problem
um and uh so
the final problem is also i think of the
independent interest
we have a problem parameter which is the
hamiltonian term and some constant
the input is some number and we want to
compute
the ground energy of our system on a
finite chain of length l
to withstand some position
so this is sort of the function version
of the problem um
daniel goddess and i studied the the
classical sort of decision version of
the problem and showed that it was
qma complete and our results are that
this function problem
is contained in fp to the qmax
and hard for fp to the next and again
there's this sort of quantum
classical gap in our results
okay so just a little bit of a word we
have sort of an exponential difference
between the finite and the infinite case
um in the infinite case um we're given
n which is the desired number of bits in
precision
so we want to get within one over two to
the n
in the finite case the input is n the
size of the system itself which is
and we want to get within one over poly
of that um
so roughly in in the infinite case
approximating alpha not to within one
over n requires
a system size of polynomial and n so
this
essentially requires um a system size of
two to the n
since the input is expressed in binary n
that results in the double exponential
from an expressibility standpoint when
we're doing
uh a reduction we can use every single
value of
n to encode the answer to a problem
in the infinite case the best we could
hope for
is recording the answer in every single
bit of alpha naught
which requires the system size to double
for every
solution that we want to encode so
that's accounts for the double
exponent and so this is closely related
to
a line of work initiated by andrus in
2014
which is about approximating the value
of local observables applied to low
energy states
of a given local hamiltonian so this is
arguably closer
to sort of capturing so the challenge of
a computational condensed metaphysicist
i mean they're not given these arbitrary
bounds
from a local hamiltonian they're they
just have a hamiltonian they want to
know something about the ground state or
they want to know the ground energy
and this type of problem naturally leads
to oracle complexity classes
because at the end of the day you not
only have to
say measure the value of the local
observable on some state you have to
verify
that it's the ground state itself and
this and all of the upper bounds are
some sort of binary search
to a qma or qmax oracle in which you're
sort of
verifying that the energy of the the
ground energy of your system is a given
value
so um oracle complexity classes seem to
be inherent in this type of problem
um so all of the results
in this sort of uh line of work make use
of
um sort of an old technique which was
used to show
um study the optimization version of
certain np
card problems and show that they're hard
for the class s
fp to the next
the idea is you're taking some function
and i'll
describe it here in terms of our
complexity classes in fp to the next
so f is computed by a polynomial time
turing machine
that makes a polynomial number of
queries
it it has access to an oracle in next
and so it has
has access to some an oracle for some
language
that has an exponential time verifier
and we want to embed this
problem into a hamiltonian
so that um if there's a good
approximation of the ground energy
we can then capture the value of f of x
okay so um we have to sort of make sure
that we're embedding the correct
computation in the ground energy
now so the scheme basically
is a cost function um and i'm
looking here i'm y is a string that
represents my guesses for what the
oracle responses are
okay so i have to simulate this p to the
fp to the next
oracle and for a particular string of
guesses
then it's just a polynomial time
computation on on input x
and the string of guesses y so we're
going to devise a cost function
that ensures that the minimum value of
this cost function happens
for the correct string
okay so once i have x and i have my
guess for the
oracle responses then i can certainly
generate
all of the inputs i can simulate p i
have my guesses for the responses
i can go through and sit and generate
all of the
um inputs that i would generate to the
oracle
okay so just as a rough sketch of how
this cost scheme works
i can use my verifier to verify yes
guesses
i can't verify no guesses so
i can verify yes guesses by simulating
the verifier
and if it's a rejecting computation i'm
going to have a large catastrophic
okay if it's for every no gas i can't
simulate that
but i'm going to have a much more modest
cost
okay so i'm sort of penalizing no
guesses just inherently
and i'm penalizing incorrect yes guesses
catastrophically
so the the costs have to be adaptive in
this case
because um the queries are adapted so
the the costs have to decrease
exponentially
because if i have an incorrect guess
on one particular the benefit i might
get
for using an incorrect guess on one
query has to outweigh
any benefit i would get for all of the
rest of the queries
so necessarily in the scheme is an
exponentially decreasing cost function
to make this work
so the costs have to depend on the input
so the challenge for us here
is to implement this in a
translationally invariant way
so i have to implement this cost
function but i have to use it
using a finite hamiltonian
um so we use um kataya's classic
um circuit to hamiltonian construction
and uh so this results in a ground state
where we have some clock and some
computation
and the um the ground state is the
uniform superposition of all points in
this computation
typically this is uh one half this
results in a
matrix that's one half times the
laplacian of
a path graph and a plus one depending on
whether the computation is rejecting or
accepting so this is what gives us the
gap
i'm going to skip over this part for the
interest of time
our construction uses a cyclical block
so it's a cycle so the propagation
hamiltonian
is the laplacian of a cycle every
computation
accepting rejecting there's no accepting
and rejecting every computation has two
consecutive
one-half penalty terms and we give exact
bounds or an exact expression for the
ground energy or the
lowest eigenvalue of this matrix which
is 1 minus cosine pi over l plus 1. so
this is precise
and what this allows us to do is it
allows us to calibrate the energy of the
ground energy
by varying the length of the cycle
so i can have shorter cycles which are
going to have higher energy
and bigger cycles which are going to
have lower energy and this is how we
implement that input dependent cost
function
um so the
the computational process basically uh
runs the binary counter and some
checking
um i wanna i've only got a couple more
minutes so
i will um so the
basically what happens is we run a
process forward and we run a process
backwards
and that allows us to end up back up in
the same state and we just repeat this
some
t number of times so there's a
there's an iteration through this loop
that's that's
completed t times where it is some
variable
and this is what allows us to regulate
the the length of the cycle
um running the process forward and then
running the process backwards guarantees
that we end up back in the same state
and that the computation will also have
this cyclical structure to it
um so there are certain penalties that
check
for that the computation is doing the
right thing
uh which is that the penalty term for an
incorrect start
and penalty terms to make sure that the
the timer length has the correct length
um so this process
checks various things so it checks that
the input is
the input is correct so that we start on
this the correct input
it checks whether the verifier is
rejecting or not
it checks whether the timer which is
regulating the length of the
cycle is correct or not and basically
this
we're computing the length of the timer
which is implementing this cost function
so this cost function which is
allowing the which is going to reward
the correct um the correct set of oracle
gases
is going to ensure that the correct
string results in the largest t
which then results in the smallest
eigenvalue for the matrix so this
this function encapsulates the cost
function
it also encodes the output to our
the function that we're reducing from so
that we can reduce and recover the input
and so uh another
feature of the analysis is that we have
to be able to
sort of um penalize
computations that don't have so for
example that have rejecting computations
or the incorrect timer length or start
on the wrong
input and we can do that
these have a periodic cost so these
happen
if i look back at the computation these
happen once a cycle
then it gets penalized so the resulting
matrix that i get
[Music]
is again the laplacian of the cycle but
now the
the penalties are having happening once
every
cycle through this graph and so we also
need a lower bound for this which is
uh one over a constant times the
interval
between the penalties so that also
required an additional
analysis to um to get something that was
independent of the size of the matrix
okay so this is the essential uh outcome
is that this hilbert space is divided
into blocks
if y has the correct incorrect yes guess
then there's a catastrophic cost which
takes it out of the running
otherwise the ground energy of the block
is
this function and
and we ensure the fact that um
[Music]
that it's going to be minimized
or maximized for the correct y so for a
given
um approximation of lambda i can get the
correct
this correct value of this function from
which i can then extract
the output to my function
okay so let me just say a couple of
words now about uh
sort of the biggest open question is
sort of to tighten up the difference
between
um the hardness results
and the containment result um i
mentioned at the beginning
that there are several differences
between np
and qma qma has a quantum verifier
qma has a quantum witness and
it has invalid queries so you can
imagine an intermediary class
which is a language version of trma so
quantum witness
quantum verifier no invalid instances
um as it turns out our construction can
easily be made hard for this
oracle class so
since this isn't a a class of particular
interest
we simplified our lives and wrote it up
for the classical version
um but we can handle
quantum witnesses and quantum verifiers
it's just the invalid instances that
throw everything off
um and just to sort of illustrate why
that's true
so this circuit to hamiltonian
construction
simulates a verifier for oracle
languages on queries
at the end of the day the acceptance
probability
is translated into the energy
and if you have invalid queries
it results in a completely unknown and
uncontrolled minimum energy
so if you're trying to embed the answer
of a computational problem
into this energy it's problematic if you
don't know what it is
and you can't control it so that's where
the
that's really where the problem comes
from and interestingly this is an issue
even in the non-translationally finite
case
so we leave as an open question um
what's the complexity of the function
version of local hamiltonian so i give
you a hamiltonian
not translationally invariant and i ask
you to compute
um the ground energy of this
hamiltonian to within a given level of
precision and so we don't know the
the complexity of this question so it
seems like a natural question
and so it's certainly uh an
uh a challenge in the infinite
translationally invariant case but it's
also an issue for the
the regular garden variety local
hamiltonian problem so
and i will end with that open question
did you on behalf of everyone
thanks a lot for the talk uh so we have
time for a question
or daniel raised her hand president
yeah i sang it so um do you you know
you have a bound on um if it's just a
purely classical hamiltonian do you know
what happens then
we don't know um so
uh right so that it turns what
the computations that we're embedding
are all classical computations because
our verifiers are classical
um but i don't know the complexity it
might be that you know there's
um i got a peek at the the paper by
uh james and toby and they might address
that problem so i'm not sure though
if it's purely classical um and for us
the problem was
this issue of betting embedding into the
robinson tiling
um so we kind of needed the quantum
version
because the ground energies are small in
the quantum version so when you
look at the circuit the hamiltonian you
know
constructions those result in one over
poly ground energies
and it's a question of the robustness of
the robinson tiling so
you have to make sure that the costs of
this 1d chain
aren't so large that they outweigh the
costs
of violating the robinson tiling
so you have to make sure that the
optimal ground energy
is going to be a correct robinson tiling
and that
it's going to be worth it to incur the
cost of these additional finite chains
um because a robinson tiling error would
be so large in comparison to it
so that's sort of where we sort of ran
into the problem
so so then james in the chart confirmed
that the paper test
does contain the classical version uh um
hi sandy can you hear me yep great uh
wonderful talk
um i just had a quick question about
this paper of krentyl right that you
guys mentioned
right so there's uh it's a paper i've
thought about before and um
but one thing i've always wondered about
that is that i mean in that paper you
know they show that
if you have a polynomial number of
queries to an npr call then that allows
you to compute kind of exponential bits
of precision to your optimization
problem right
and the problem when you think about
quantum analogs of this is right is that
the oracle only gives you one over poly
precision
right so it's not clear that doing a
polynomial number of queries to this
thing can give you exponential precision
in anything
right right and i think you guys seem to
get around that because you're you're
acquiring a
q a x oracle let's say you're a next
oracle so you really do get that very
fine precision
so i was totally at a losses as to what
to do with like krentel's result right
if you think about
p to the q a let's say versus p to the q
a log
and i'm just wondering if you guys have
thought about that or
yeah we didn't because of the
translational variance we're sort of
inherently in this stage yeah that comes
naturally that's right yeah
we're in qax so we didn't have that we
didn't have that issue
um so we didn't think about and another
thing that's sort of related to that
is your result that you know a
polynomial number of adaptive queries is
the same as an exponential number of
um parallel queries and we
tried to think of ways in which that
would help us reduce the dependence on
the input but
in our construction that didn't seem to
work so we stuck with the adaptive
adapter okay
good thank you
so can i uh can i ask a question
okay yeah so uh in one of the slides you
mentioned that
uh that by blocking you can estimate the
the ground residence you have to add
epsilon
is that the best algorithm you would
imagine for this problem like just from
computational point of view you mean the
binary search
just right like uh to compute the ground
energy density up to error epsilon you
could make blocks of size
poly1 or epsilon and then just solve
locally
yeah and that's basically what we
suggest doing is that that's the best
known
so you just basically solve it you know
you have a finite system and then you
have you know
queries to an oracle that will tell you
that will help you compute the ground
energy of that finite system
and then the sort of the the error
around the edges
is small compared to the bulk of the
system so that's the best
that's the best we're aware of i see and
is that what that gives the continent
in fp to the power qma x yes
okay thanks both looking at finite
systems exactly
okay
i wanted to ask about um
so you presented the containment for
starting from a fp to the nx algorithm
and then you kind of said well um it
sort of seemed like straightforward that
you can extend it to the
i guess fp to the qmax
assuming you don't have to deal with
this promise
um so is that the case it is
straightforward when you presented it i
thought this is never going to extend
because you list
it's it's for the infinite case we'll
need
um qma1
and the reason is the best you can do is
the and the reason is
kind of i described earlier is that you
need to be able to determine
these um ground energy densities exactly
for accepting computations and
and the ground energy always depends on
your likelihood of acceptance or your
probability of error
so we can't afford any error in the
in the accepting computations so qma one
is the best we can hope for for the
infinite case
um most everything in the construction
generalizes
there is a little bit of extra work to
be done because
um this hamiltonian term that
penalizes a rejecting computation is now
not perfectly diagonal on your standard
basis anymore
so there's a little bit of extra work to
do but it it
it's not too bad so um it can be done
um yeah
but the class um and so this is just
ignorance but but the class
uh whatever however that would be so
that doesn't contain
anything that's not in np or what like a
qma
xl which i you mean the language version
of qma is that
yeah yeah yeah i we don't know if any
this is sort of the first that class
occurred to us
only because that's what comes out of
the construction so i'm not aware of any
interesting problems in that class or
complete for that class
yeah if we had we would have written up
our results for that hardness i guess so
okay thanks
we have a minute or two for some more
questions
if i may bug you again since there's
some time um you mentioned this nice
open problem at the end right with the
function
uh local hamiltonian yeah yeah so um
if i remember correctly andres's paper
in 2014 right had this claim for
um something similar not exactly the
same right it's still a decision problem
it wants to know if the exact energy is
you know it's upper and lower bounds on
the energy and i think there he defines
a class like dqma or something like this
that's
um that's a quantum analog of dp you're
given the value and you want to verify
that value
i think so yeah yeah but it's not the
function version you're not outputting
this thing
right right so um
i mean have you guys thought about that
connection or i mean that's the obvious
place to start i guess right
yeah that is and then you know so
there's an analog question
in mp2 so you know is min value this
you know exactly this value um and and i
and i think i don't know how that works
is the fact that
andres did sort of originally overlook
this invalid query
that was i think part of it an
understandable mistake because we did
for a long time as well so
so i think that might be the issue there
so but it would
but that is a good place to start is if
you're given the value and just sort of
verify a particular value is within
epsilon of the ground energy
certainly a good place to start
okay great um thanks let's uh thanks
sandy again for another talk
thanks a lot um
so the next speaker of the morning